bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen à bruxelles en
ligne en mai il existe une ville en
europe pour le tourisme sexuel est
florissant riga capitale de la lettonie
petites banques européennes enquête dans
cette émission l'actualité cette semaine
ce sont les européens qui s'inquiètent
des révolutions dans le monde arabe
les occidentaux en général et les
européens en particulier ont ils été
complices des dictateurs c'est la
question de cette semaine le colonel
moammar kadhafi a toujours été le
bienvenu en europe
accueillis très chaleureusement par le
président du conseil européen en
personne le guide suprême dictateur
notoire vaut bien quelques salutations
appuyer ou quelques premier plan sur les
photos de famille il les vaut bien avec
son pétrole à foison l'un des plus purs
au monde pendant plus de vingt ans le
commerce international a primé sur les
droits de l'homme
oublié aussi les attentats contre les
vols de la panam et de lutter à mouammar
kadhafi serait devenu selon ses
partenaires européens un rempart au
terrorisme international
oui mais voilà quand un scirocco
révolutionnaire se met à souffler il
suffit parfois de quelques jours pour
voir tomber les pire des dictatures et
avec elle les certitudes des diplomates
bien sûr certains n'ont jamais soutenu
le régime autrement que du bout des
lèvres
d'autres ont fait moins de manière
intérêt économique oblige mais pendant
que le sang coule l'europe dans
l'urgence cherche un remède aux erreurs
du passé
fini les armes les munitions les
cartouches
le colonel kadhafi est désormais persona
non grata en europe du tapis rouge à la
liste noire il n'y a parfois qu'un pas
bref l'europe est elle complice alors
nous avons été rejoints sur ce plateau
par dominique baudis bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes député européen vous
êtes vice président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et par ailleurs vous
êtes le président de l'institut du monde
arabe
quand on voit ces images d'archivés ces
images terribles
est ce qu'on peut dire que les européens
aujourd'hui avait tort et que la
diplomatie européenne
si elles existent devrait faire un mea
culpa des gens que cet exercice de
flagellation d'autoflagellation depuis
des semaines de la part des européens
est vraiment contre-productif quand on
voit ce sujet on voit bien que le monde
entier les chefs d'état du monde entier
entretenez des relations avec kadhafi
comme dans le monde entier on en retire
c'est un des résultats des relations
avec des chefs d'état quelles que soient
les régimes
ce ne sont que des progrès qu'ils ont
fabriqué le régime kadhafi c'est un état
riverain la méditerranée il ya eu des
moments très difficiles notamment dans
la période terroristes de kadhafi aux
attentes en mai puis allez moment où il
a pu entendre raison par exemple quand
il a libéré les infirmières bulgares ça
n'excuse pas le fait qu'ils aient été
détenus pendant des mois mais de temps
en temps des messages pouvaient passer
quoi qu'il en soit dans les relations
internationales
on ne choisit pas ses interlocuteurs
quand on discute avec les dirigeants
chinois
c'est bien que il incarne un régime qui
est pas un modèle de démocratie c'est
l'éternel problème c'est ce qu'il faut
favoriser les les droits de l'homme où
les intérêts week
quand on veut favoriser les droits de
l'homme dans un pays où ils ne sont pas
respectées il ya plusieurs façons on
peut faire passer des messages
ils sont entendus et où ils ne le sont
pas on peut prendre des mesures de
rétorsion comme par exemple un moment
donné les états unis et la communauté
internationale l'ont fait avec l'irak
qui en a souffert
saddam hussein où le peuple irakien
c'est le peuple irakien qui a subi le
poids des sanctions
et puis après dernière étape ya la
guerre effectivement beaucoup de pays
occidentaux pas la france heureusement
sont partis en guerre en irak pour
renverser une dictature
on voit le résultat dans le pays est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment quand
même qu'aujourd'hui une page s'est
tournée j'ai que les diplomaties
mondiales d'ailleurs pas uniquement un
diplomatie européenne les diplomaties ne
pourront plus entretenir les mêmes
relations avec les dictatures qu'il ya
encore quelques semaines c'est possible
c'est possible ce qui se passe dans le
monde arabe a surpris tout le monde
moi j'attends qu'on me montre
une dépêche diplomatique ou un article
de presse du mois d'octobre du mois de
novembre
10 ans ça va tomber le régime libyen va
tomber le régime va tomber personne ne
l'avait vu venir c'est un peu dans le
sud du mur berlin
donc ce
battre la coulpe en dix ans personne ne
l'avait vu venir mais évidemment c'est
une nouvelle page qui s'écrit
ça va être une longue histoire on peut
dater le début des révolutions fin
décembre en tunisie janvier en egypte
février en libye
mais quand viendra la fin et de quelle
façon viendra-t-elle aujourd'hui nul ne
peut le dire
alors à ce sujet justement vous suivent
évidemment très près ce qui se passe on
est très prudent parce que tout évolue
d'heure en heure les américains ont
envoyé des forces dans sur zone en tout
cas en méditerranée il ya des marines
qui sont qui sont déployés est ce que
vous craignez un embrasement généralisé
dans la région
dans l'immédiat on est face à une crise
humanitaire de dimension catastrophique
on a déjà plus de cent mille personnes
qui ont quitté la libye qui arrivent en
tunisie encore bien d'autres qui veulent
passer avec la situation qu'on va
connaître en libye pendant des semaines
sinon des mois il y aura des départs de
personnes qui vivaient là qui sont des
étrangers à la libye donc il faut très
très vite mettre en place un dispositif
humanitaire
un dispositif humanitaire d'une grande
envergure il faut un dispositif de
grande envergure et il doit s'appuyer
sur des logistiques puissante et je
pense que l'armée américaine est en
englobant également des unités d'armée
européenne pourront appuyer leurs
efforts pour loger soigner et rapatriés
là les personnes qui se trouvent sur cet
aspect là on voit les américains avec
des militaires dont pour d'humanitaire
mais des européens ils sont où
s'il y ait des unités françaises qui
feront 16 mai avec pavillon européen
avec pavillon en paya pas encore bon
mais ça sera une décision à prendre dans
les jours qui viennent puisque les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement des vingt-sept
vont se réunir pour examiner les mesures
humanité
d'urgence pour appréhender la façon dont
on va faire face et on va pouvoir
contenir le mouvement migratoire qui va
probablement se produire en direction du
sud vers le nord et l'europe se trouvera
la première concernée comment
accompagner ces pays qui vont entrer
dans des périodes d'incertitude et
d'instabilité
comment faire en sorte que les
difficultés sociales d'un pays comme la
tunisie ou comme l'égypte difficultés
qui en tunisie était à l'origine le sol
rivaux du mouvement ça que ces partis ne
s'aggrave pas est ce que vous imaginez
bien la tunisie doit à l'heure actuelle
supporter le pour des gens qui arrivent
de libye
une certitude une politique qui ne
favorise pas évidemment la confiance et
le retour par exemple des touristes ne
faut pas oublier que le tourisme fournit
à peu près un tiers des emplois directs
ou indirects de la tunisie alors on va
on va voir un petit peu maintenant
dominique baudis vous restez avec nous
on va voir comment les télévisions
européennes évidemment j'ai envie de
dire qu'ils sont aux premières loges ont
traité de cette actualité depuis
maintenant trois semaines et puis
ensuite on sera rejoint par sergio
cantone qui est correspondant permanent
d'euronews ici à bruxelles mais d'abord
on regarde ce zapping des télévisions
européennes tunis où un show de
l'immigration clandestine vers l'europe
des centaines de jeunes partent
régulièrement d'ici pour rejoindre
lampedusa
makram et lui aussi candidat à
l'immigration il a essayé trois fois en
deux ans de rejoindre ville la dernière
fois c'était il ya dix jours il est
parti avec des amis sur un zodiac au
moment de la chute de ben ali méritait
les conditions météo étaient mauvaises
alors on a dû rebrousser chemin
alors les autorités doivent maintenant
décongestionner le centre d'amp et 12 à
premier centre d'accueil de cette
immigration quatre vols militaires avec
400 tunisiens à bord ont été prévus ils
sont évacués non pas en raison des
mauvaises conditions météo
mais tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a
plus de places dans les centres
d'accueil en italie leur voyage s'est
arrêté en gare de bologne 118
clandestins interceptés hier par les
carabiniers a priori des tunisiens
débarqués ce week-end sur l'île de
lampedusa
beaucoup voulaient rejoindre vintimille
une des portes d'accès à la france où
vivent six cent mille tunisiens
autre axe est possible et direct la
corse et ses 1000 47 km de côtes
cette immigration ne concerne pas
seulement l'île de lampedusa et l'italie
c'est aussi un problème pour l'union
européenne parce que tous ces tunisiens
qui arrivent ici vise d'autres
destinations comme la france et n'ont
pas forcément les talibans c'est
pourquoi les autorités italiennes
estiment qu'elles ne doivent pas être
les seuls à affronter ce problème
alors voilà pour le traitement de cette
actualité européenne forte de ces
derniers jours nous sommes avec sergio
cantone bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
correspondant permanent d'euronews ici à
bruxelles
est-ce que les télévisions européennes
pour ce que vous en avez vu et pour la
vôtre ont traité je dirais de manière
uniforme un peu cette crainte d'une
immigration massive en europe
oui oui comme un peu toute cette crise
si la partie concernant de l'immigration
à la carte surtout parce que là on parle
d'immigration mais c'est surtout une
crainte parce que les chiffres et
déborde par ceux qui sont d'habitude les
chiffres ça va commencer en tout cas non
ça n'a pas commencé c'est ce qu'on
attend en tout cas oui elle a été
des tracts et par toutes les télévisions
plus ou moins de la même manière
bien sûr les télévisions disons des pays
riverains de la méditerranée ont
sensibilité plus
elles sont plus sensibles à l'argument
la question et ça c'est clair c'est
évident mais toute l'europe ça
l'inquiète est-ce que c'est présenté de
façon un peu sensationnaliste oui mais
comme comme désormais beaucoup de sujets
les sujets concernant l'immigration là
les droits de l'homme et surtout le sud
de la méditerranée ça c'est évident il
ya des sensations au nazisme c'est
évident dominique baudis est ce que les
télévisions européennes et les européens
en général ont raison de s'inquiéter de
cette éventuelle vague massive
d'immigrants est évident parce qu'on est
confronté à deux problèmes d'une part
des gens qui fuient des zones
dangereuses comme par exemple les
personnes qui fuient la région de
tripoli
en ce moment donc il ya une urgence
alors elle a un caractère humanitaire
dans un premier temps il faut que ces
gens soient accueillis soigner logés
nourris et puis ensuite il faut essayer
de les acheminer vers leurs pays
d'origine
et là il ya tout un travail qui devra se
faire entre l'union européenne et
l'union africaine qui doit aussi prendre
ses responsabilités il s'agirait de
façon très égoïste et un autre côté de
même si c'est très proche et d'autre de
la méditerranée mais ce qu'on a on avoir
peur que ces gens là où ils puissent la
méditerranée aura une inspiration
du sud vers vers le nord au delà même de
la crise violente
en ce moment vous allez avoir qu'on le
veuille ou non j'espère de la manière la
plus brève possible mais on aura
fatalement des difficultés économiques
en tunisie et des difficultés
économiques en egypte ne serait ce qu'en
raison je l'indiqué tout à l'heure de la
chute de la fréquentation touristique
qui est l'activité qui fournit le plus
d'emplois dans ces deux pays et que par
conséquent le nombre de chômeurs et en
particulier du jeune chômeur dans un
premier temps on va plutôt augmenter et
n'oubliez pas que c'est cette
frustration justement des diplômés
chômeurs qui a été à l'origine des
premiers troubles sociaux au début des
événements en tunisie
est ce que le risque sérieux quand on s
est pas de justement pour les
télévisions et pour les médias en
général de focaliser sur ces aspects
d'immigration et de monter je dirais un
peu en épingle un problème qui
finalement pour l'instant n'existe pas
il ya le risque
le problème dire qu'il n'existe pas
c'est peut-être exagéré le problème
existe objectivement où on doit être
préparé même si après ils ne se vérifie
pas mais quand même il faut il faut que
les états il faut que l'union européenne
va préparer à l'éventualité donc je ne
pense pas que les télévisions sont en
train d dramatiser la situation
c'est évident que il ya des inquiétudes
de la part de l'opinion publique ça
c'est clair de l'opinion publique
européenne
mais après comment gérer la situation
ça sera je pense à l'union européenne
par aux médias alors évidemment on va
suivre ça également ici dans l'europe
des bleus et plus largement bien sûr sur
les chaînes parlementaires
messieurs merci beaucoup l'émission se
poursuit on va aller tout à l'heure avec
kathia gilder mais tout de suite et bien
nous partons à riga en lettonie alors on
le sait peu mais riga est un malade
malheureusement un haut-lieu européen du
tourisme sexuel
c'est un reportage dont kariya qui est
signé yoann ré là mais nuit dans les
rues du vieux riga le début d'une
nouvelle patrouille de la police
touristique
une unité spéciale kelly et nate et loi
et son collègue ont rejointe il ya
presque deux ans ce soir c'est un
vendredi très froid mais les vendredis
soirs c'est là qu'on travaille le plus
l'émission de ce nouveau service de
police sanctionner la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique bien sûr
vous pouvez me montrer vos papiers mais
surtout effacer la prostitution et les
clubs douteux du centre historique
quelques mètres plus loin elena est fier
de nous montrer la première victoire de
son service un salon de massage qu'ils
ont fait fermer il ya presque un an
vous savez les patrons de ce genre
d'endroit se connaissent bien et ils
parlent entre eux on leur a donné un
avertissement
quand on a fermé ce salon de massage
trois ou quatre autres ont plié boutique
tout de suite la guerre aux proxénètes
et au business du sexe une affaire
d'état pour la lettonie dans le vieux
riga sa principale vitrine touristique
plus encore qu'ailleurs dans les bars ce
soir là pourtant beaucoup de visiteurs
masculins anglais et scandinaves
officiellement ils sont seulement venu
siroter quelques bières beaucoup moins
cher que dans leur pays d'origine mais
tous semblent avoir une idée bien
arrêtée sur les filles méthode si tu as
de l'argent tu peux avoir une fille
et bien c'est a pas d'argent ben tapati
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire juste un
whisky je m'amuse avec mes amis et je me
tape des filles
non tu veux dire que tu leur fais un
gros câlin bien sûr oui bien sûr un gros
câlin rien 10 juin riga ville propre
chez les touristes le message n'est pas
encore passé
depuis quelques années l'autre
attraction de la ville où la bière coule
à flot est devenue l'organisation
d'enterrement de vie de garçon
c'est un regard ne regarde c'est le
futur marié là bas allez viens là assume
c'est toi le futur marié c'est qu'il
futurs mariés t'inquiète bien là ta
femme un père à rien le voyage se passe
bien
ouais super c'est vraiment une belle
aventure une aventure équivoque car les
activités nocturnes proposés sur
internet aux futurs mariés sont souvent
les mêmes
une virée dans les clubs de strip-tease
de la ville pour les tours opérators
pourtant pas question de servir de boucs
émissaires dans la plus grande
discothèque du pays
anastasia organise presque chaque week
end et enterrements de vie de garçon une
activité qui selon elle n'a rien à voir
avec du tourisme sexuel
ils viennent s'amuser danser je pense
pas que ce soit des touristes sexuels le
monde suspecte viennent plutôt des
petits groupes d'individus isolés dans
ce cas je leur explique que je ne peux
rien faire pour eux et ça serait plaint
mais si pour anastasia le service
s'arrête là d'autres n'ont pas les mêmes
scrupules pour trouver plus à riga le
premier taxi qui passe fait souvent la
faire si vous voulez du sexe je connais
un endroit super on vous pouvez avoir
des massages et même des relations avec
les filles
et ça coûte combien ces 80 euros de
l'heure mais les filles sont vraiment
très belles et vous pouvez même les
choisir d'un véhicule à l'autre
direction la périphérie de la ville
dans ce mini bus chaque soir wenceslas
part à la rencontre des femmes qui
arpentait trottoirs de riga avec son
équipe il travaille pour une ong de
lutte contre le sida aux filles ils
distribuent des préservatifs mais aussi
des seringues et des aiguilles 9
triste constat la plupart de ces
prostituées sont aussi toxicomane
loin du centre-ville et pourtant tout
proche des clients étrangers
c'est souvent vous voyez des clients
étrangers
oui oui très souvent quand je vois des
étrangers en général je les reconnais et
je leur demande 10 euros de plus mais
souvent il me donne encore plus que ce
que je demande
avec eux je peux facilement 70 euros en
une heure 70 euros c'est un tiers du
salaire minimum les tons une fortune
wenceslas ne cache pas son inquiétude
la lettonie est aussi l'un des pays les
plus durement touchés par la crise
européenne
le problème c'est que tous ces facteurs
se conjuguent la crise d'un côté mais
aussi cette mauvaise réputation du pays
continue à attirer beaucoup d'européens
avec toutes ces femmes qui manque
d'argent pour survivre
on peut difficilement faire pire comme
situation en lettonie
aucune statistique officielle mais selon
les estimations les plus basses
les prostituées serait
proportionnellement cinq fois plus
nombreuses dans le pays qu'en france
malgré les efforts des autorités pour
débarrasser rigade son image de capitale
européenne du tourisme sexuel
la ville pourrait bien mettre un peu
plus de temps que prévu à redorer son
blason
voilà pour ce sujet signé yoan rla dans
les rues de riga
elisabeth morin chartier est avec nous
bonjour vous êtes vice présidente de la
commission des droits de la femme et de
l'égalité des genres ici au parlement
européen alors on a choisi ce sujet un
peu choc à l'occasion de la journée de
la femme que l'on célèbre ce mardi 8
mars est ce que quand on vous voyez ce
reportage ce genre de prince des deux
pratiques ou simplement vous choque
bien sûr je suis choquée mais je suis
lucide et c'est la triste réalité et
cette réalité là elle est intimement
liée non seulement à la place de la
femme dans la société mais surtout à la
place de la femme dans l'économie et
dans le monde du travail c'est que un
secteur comme celui ci ne peut se
développer que parce que la femme n'a
pas sa place
aujourd'hui la place qu'elles devraient
avoir dans le travail qu'elle ne gagne
pas sa vie normalement avec un travail
normal une intégration dans l'entreprise
donc c'est lié à la formation des femmes
à leur intégration est aussi aux
représentations mentales et à la façon
dont la femme est considérée justement
quand on voit ce genre de réalité quand
même assez violente
est-ce que vous devrez pas un peu
hypocrite de célébrer donc cette journée
internationale de la femme parce que là
c'est le symbole là on a quand même la
réalité alors qu'on soit très très
clairs sur la journée internationale de
la femme
cette journée elle est faite pour mettre
en éclairage un certain nombre de
problèmes très graves qui se posent aux
femmes et qui souligne les inégalités
des femmes
ce que vous faites à travers ce
reportage et ça c'est formidable mais
l'action c'est toute l'année l'action
politique la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes la lutte pour que la
femme prenne sa place dans la société
la lutte contre les représentations
mentales c'est toute l'année c'est 365
jours par an et c'est toute l'éducation
depuis le berceau est ce que vous
trouvez que l'europe sur ces questions
là est en régression ou en progression
l'europe les institutions européennes et
particulièrement le parlement européen
est extrêmement engagée sur la
protection des femmes à égalité avec les
hommes sur la lutte contre les violences
sur la lutte contre la prostitution
tout ceci est très très fort mais si on
regarde la société on voit bien que dans
l'histoire on n'est pas dans une
progression constante linéaire de la
protection de la femme les féministes
voudrait nous afficher une protection
systématique et une avancée des droits
des femmes
ça n'est pas le cas il y à de tristes
revers de triste retour en arrière alors
et ceci est vraiment un exemple des tris
turvey alors pour revenir à riga les
associations n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens certaines se sentent démunis il
ya quand même des gens qui font des
choses on avait rencontré sandra
responsable d'une association dada ces
femmes elle a justement une question à
vous poser à poser à la députée
européenne à écouter aujourd'hui dans
tous les pays la législation et la
compréhension de la traite humaine sont
différentes
pensez vous qu'une législation unique au
niveau européen peut nous permettre de
venir à bout des problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui
alors est ce que le parlement européen
se préoccupe de cette question est
quelle solution et la lave
une partie de la vraie réponse est
européenne
pourquoi parce qu'on voit bien qu'à
l'intérieur des 27 états membres par
l'écart des niveaux de vie par l'écart
de l'implication de la femme dans la vie
sociale et professionnelle
on a des mouvements de population qui
stimule le tourisme sexuel et la
prostitution
donc ceci est à combattre et nous le
combattons en mettant en place au niveau
européen
une directive européenne qui s'imposent
aux états membres à que visuel ses
directives et qui lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes en
condamnant ceux qui en profitent d'une
part du contrôle des réseaux lutte
contre les profiteurs de tout cela mais
d'autre part en protégeant les femmes
par des programmes dead comme le
programme daphné qui recueille ces
femmes qui les aident à se réinsérer
je pense en particulier aux fonds social
européen dont je m'occupe le fse c'est
une partie aussi des réponses parce
qu'il nous faut intégrer ces femmes dans
la vie professionnelle
on les laisse pas sur le trottoir dans
tous les sens du terme alors certes un
certain
certaines même en france comme la
députée danielle bousquet propose de
s'en prendre aux clients elle propose
notamment de pénaliser le client c'est
une proposition qu'elle a fait est ce
que voudrait que c'est une bonne idée
c'est une idée parmi d'autres
il n'ya pas pour lutter contre ce fléau
de la prostitution
il n'y a pas une seule idée il y a
plusieurs idées
alors c'est vrai que les profiteurs les
réseaux tous les organisateurs doivent
être combattus et pourchassés
sanctionnés je suis d'accord mais ça
n'est pas la seule réponse parce que les
femmes
il faut qu'elles puissent vivre en
autonomie dignement de leur travail et
donc pour cela il y à d'autres réponses
d'autres programmes européens qui sont
là pour les aider
les maisons closes dans certains pays
des maisons closes existe est ce que
vous pensez que ça pourrait être aussi
une solution
moi je suis très mesuré là dessus je
sais que certains médecins ont d'autres
avis pour moi la maison close n'a jamais
fait partie de mon panthéon
par contre j'ai de beaucoup des maisons
faites pour recueillir des femmes qui
subissent qui ont subi des violences et
qui veulent se sortir de l'ornière
ça oui je les aide eh bien merci
beaucoup elisabeth morin-chartier
d'avoir été avec nous c'est la tradition
dans cette émission l'europe est au bout
du fil
question cette semaine de pierre qui vit
à caen et ils achètent souvent des
produits bio mais ils se sont un peu
perdus face à la prolifération de des
étiquettes alors comment être sûr qu'un
produit réellement bios et sa question
écouter la réponse de nos experts
d'europe direct
bonjour pierre
en effet l'union européenne à développer
un label bio qui atteste que les
produits bio que vous consommez
correspondent bien aux réglementations
européennes en matière de culture
biologique
ce processus d'ailleurs est lui-même
assez stricte le label lui-même est très
facile à identifier tel que vous le
voyez à l'écran maintenant il est
constitué d'un ensemble des toiles
réparties en forme de feuille sur un
fond de couleur verte
voilà vous avez bien vu ce logo des
produits bio et vous pouvez poser vos
questions aux numéros suivants 0 08 cent
6 7 8 9 10 11 appels gratuits partout en
europe
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
tous de votre fidélité
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine nous
serons astral à strasbourg bauxite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires